hi I'm Michelle Landry Klein fellow
Stanford alumni undergraduate and MBA
thank you for joining us for a
conversation about managing career
pivots it's a topic relevant to so many
people in the workforce I know that in
my career I've pivoted several times
from entertainment to management
consulting from a venture capital firm
to a not for-profit my last pivot was
about seven years ago when I helped
launch a startup called business talent
group it's also where I met our guest
speaker jod greenstone Miller jod is the
founder and CEO of business talent group
btg is a Marketplace for Independent
Business talent to connect with
companies for project-based work Jody is
also a lead thinker on the topic of the
future of work and has frequently
written for and been profiled in every
major media news Outlet before she
started btg she had made a number of
career pivots herself a lawyer by
training she was an investment banker
she was special counsel in the white
house she was COO of americast a Telco
company and she was a venture partner
with mavon Venture Capital Jody thank
you so much for being here today to
share us with us some of your ideas
about managing career pivots before we
get into strategies I'd love for you to
give us a maybe a more specific
definition of what we mean by a career
pivot it really means taking a path that
looks different than what we would
consider a traditional old style career
where you're at one company with a
pretty lock step progression it's doing
things in a different way it can also
mean when you reach a point in your
career where you'd like to learn a new
skill or learn a new industry and add
something new and change your direction
so why is it important that we have this
conversation and we're talking about
these career pivots now why is it
happening because we're seeing more and
more people face this either by choice
or because the market is moving quickly
and it's happening for a number of
reasons people personal definition of
professional success is changing the
world is changing the P the pace of
technology and globalization means that
things are moving faster we're seeing a
difference in the way employers and
employees relate to one another the
things that tie them together and we're
seeing a very big difference in the kind
of flexibility and control that people
want in their professional lives so this
feels very different than the career
path of the past yes I mean there are a
lot of differences first of all just
tenure the average job tenure today
based on uh statistics from the Bureau
of Labor is 4.4 years if you look at the
younger generation we're seeing half of
that so two and a half years at the most
that's very different than careers of
the past when people were there 25 30
years second if you're not at a company
a long time it's very hard to fit into
what would be considered the traditional
lockstep career path if you look at a
lot of very wonderful companies they
could tell you here is what you do on
day one here's what you do on 24 months
here's what you do in 36 months in fact
it was so clear what the path was that
recruiters would often be able to look
at a resume and tell you someone was
promoted to vice president in 3.6 months
actually if they were a star it would
have been 2.8 months so the Precision
and definition of what a career looked
like was really different than what
we're seeing today and you're also
seeing a rise of an independent
professional recently Elance which is an
online Market uh place for uh
Freelancers and uh for the Freelancers
Union came together and showed us that
there are 53 million people today which
is a third of the workforce who
self-identify as doing freelancer
independent work these are Big
demographic changes and I think you're
seeing that drive affect what a career
looks like has this changed the
definition of success you know that's a
really interesting question if you look
at what success was like in a a world
where your progression was predefined
what it was your title it was your
financial compensation it was some level
of control as you moved up the ladder
but it was really clear what it looked
like today people have a much more
layered vision of what success looks
like they are looking for different
things they're looking for variety
they're looking for meaning they're
looking for a far greater degree of
control over not just their daily life
but the path of their career and they're
also seeing that can get a lot of the
benefits that they would previously look
to an employer for in other places and
that's freed up the labor market and
allowed people to pursue things that are
more personally
fulfilling it feels like it's there's
sort of a new normal out there that a
nonlinear career path as you call it or
these career P pivots is is more normal
so um well I guess this would be a good
launch time to have the conversation
around what strategies have you seen
that are effective in managing through
these career pivots you have some
suggestions I think there are five
things that are helpful first just to
lay them out there are um you need to
know what you want two you need to build
your knowledge base three you need to
leverage your strengths four you need to
Market your skills and five you have to
avoid some common mistakes and I think
as we go into this world if you keep
these things in mind you'll be more
successful and have a little less stress
as you navigated because the one thing I
would say about career pivots the path
is unique for everybody and you're not
going to be able to look at your
business school associate and say I'm
going to do what you did it's a very
personalized way of thinking about your
career
[Music]
right the key here is that it's not
stagnant your life has a cycle and you
go through different periods where
different things are happening and you
value different things you need to match
up your career objectives with your life
cycle which is something that was not
even possible in a world of a
traditional career right you did what
you did you were promoted when you were
promoted but you have events in your
life you have marriages you have
children you have illness you have
hobbies you love and what you want to do
is to take a longer View and look at
your life and what you want to
accomplish in your life as a whole and
then look at your career and put them
together and figure out what it is you
want from your career at different
points in your life and by the way just
because it looks a certain way on day
one doesn't mean 3 years later it's
going to look the same it's a constant
process and you know you want to use
different kinds of resources because
this is hard you want to go to your
friends and your colleagues you want to
go to the kind of services that Stanford
has I know they have great Stanford has
actually some some excellent Services um
and I'll I have a good example of a
friend that he was he was a career
independent uh or Management Consultant
uh very successful career he loved his
work he after a few year a number of
years the work and his lifestyle were
just it's kind of to your point there
was he was at a different stage in his
life and it didn't work anymore so he
undertook this path of trying to figure
out what it was that he wanted and it is
hard because you someone say you you
know what you want that's a really hard
question to to ask yourself so he
actually did turn to Stanford and
Stanford has this great um it's called
the career and life visioning Workshop
out of the business school and he did
that and there was a number of self
assessment tools and from do from from
going through this process he was able
to tease out what it was that he really
wanted and as a result he actually
switched careers into financial
management so I interrupted you there
but that was no but I think I think the
really important point is this is new
yeah the idea that we have the ability
to think about our careers and match it
up with our life is something that is
impossible in a very traditional old
style career so this is a this is an
opportunity and it's a way in which
every individual has now a choice and
you've got to be realistic too if you
say I want to be the CEO of a fortune 5
fun company or a high growth Venture
company you know you've got to
understand what it means to do those uh
particular jobs and whether in fact you
can make it mesh with whatever else you
want to do so it It's A Hard Exercise
but it's the foundation to any career
pivot you have to know where you're
you're trying to go to and what you
[Music]
want first you want to understand your
gaps you know what do you know what
skills do you have what experiences do
you have and what do you need for where
it is you want to go next right and
really doing an inventory and
understanding there may be hard skills
that you need you may want to go into
financial analysis and you don't know
how to do an Excel spreadsheet so it may
be something as simple as that or it may
be you know learning a whole new
industry so there are a lot of resources
for that you can go to conferences you
can read trade Publications you can take
classes at mukes I know Stanford's very
involved with the the the offering of
online courses so I think you want to
just get your grounding your knowledge
grounded um but then the harder part is
finding the experience finding the entry
point finding a way to get real life
tests right first of whether you even
like the way you're going to Pivot
because you may not and to get a way in
because it's very difficult to make a
pivot and have someone immediately you
may get lucky but have someone
immediately say oh you're now doing this
and you've never done this before okay
so so how do you go and get that
experience so I think there are a couple
tools you can use I think one project
work is a great way to go into a new
Arena it's great for you because you get
to test it out and it's great for an
employer because they get to test you
out it's not as big a commitment and
they're much more willing to take a risk
if it's a Define project that um that
they can see how you do right two I
think proon work I think it is um very
often possible to find Opportunities to
make a contribution in a pro bono way
that also give you new skills you know
if you're taking the finance example you
know you could go into a major nonprofit
and help them redo their Treasury
Department you know they would be
grateful and you would learn a lot and
you would both benefit I think the third
idea that I I like is that internships
should not just be for people in their
20s I mean you know if you have
something you want to learn and you have
something to offer just like interns
have something to offer you should go
and say I'd like to intern for you and
you know really create the opportunity
to go in and expand your experience base
I hadn't thought about that you really
think of internship as you know several
years younger than I am but that that
makes a lot of sense if you're trying to
build that experience have you do you
have any examples of people that have
done this well well there's a a woman I
know who was in Investment Banking and
who was a consultant who decided want to
get an education and so lots of places
you can learn about education a lot
written about it a lot of lot of
conferences a lot of blogs got up the
learning curve and in fact took a pro
boner role in an educational institution
which gave her the experience that made
her credible to make that
IND I think this is a really um a really
important one because most professionals
have skills of some variety right you've
got to break them apart and understand
them and how you can make them
applicable to where you want to go so
let's take a couple examples the first
is if you are a functional executive so
you know about human resour you know the
legal department you know Communications
you know Finance you know marketing if
you think about it very even sales a lot
of what organizations have to do are
functional skills those are very very
transferable and in fact the fact that
you're coming from a different industry
may make you more desirable because you
can bring lessons from one industry to
another that can be really helpful so if
you're in a functional area you are
probably the most uh well positioned to
make make a career easy to transfer
those skills but there are things you
might not have thought about that are
also really transferable skills if you
have been in startups and you've helped
scale a company from you know two
pulleys to 20 to 100 to a thousand
that's a very replicable skill and
that's useful to a lot of people even
industry you know you're in you and I
were both uh in entertainment if we
wanted to Pivot to technology which is
now a very exciting place to be how do
you use your entertainment experience
well you've got a lot of technology
companies that need to partner or sell
to entertainment companies you are very
valuable to them so you can use that
industry knowledge to transfer to a
different industry the one great example
of that is government um if you look
around in government you'll see cabinet
secretaries who have been you know
cabinet Secretary of um Treasury and
then Secretary of State or head of the
Office of Management and budget and then
Secretary of Defense I mean the
government actually has done a really
good job maybe better better than the
private sector of recognizing that
there's a core set of skills that if a
manager has that can be put into at the
highest levels of you know importance in
the world can be
transferred so it's something to think
about and to look at your skill set and
see the gold nuggets in it right and
pull them out and be able to imagine how
you could apply them in a new a new
venue this actually reminds me of
someone that and I think you're going to
know who I'm talking about that works
their company yes who is a she's just a
career manager and she' she'd had many
many many years of career of uh you know
High Pate jobs and Fortune 100 companies
but if you looked at what that skill was
it was so transferable she can just
manage her way through anything right
and the fact that she'd been in and then
she came you know to business talent
group but the fact that she'd been in
all these different Industries I think
gives her perspective that much more you
know oomph and value and and the thing
that's really interesting about her is
she took a number of years off I think
six or seven so a significant amount of
time to pursue some personal objectives
when I looked at her what was clear to
me is the skills she had didn't go away
right she didn't forget how to manage
you don't lose that muscle and that's an
important thing to remember too that you
know just because you knew a skill and
you haven't done it for a while it's
like riding a bike you you don't lose it
and so don't be afraid right and don't
diminish your knowledge because you may
have taken a a path that you know took
you on a different place for a couple
years these are coures skills and you
should be able to leverage them and use
them in your new
[Music]
Direction You also mentioned uh
marketing yourself as a important um
strategy to have and I think this is one
that some people find daunting to put
yourself out there and say here's what I
do here are my skills it can can feel
awkward so do you have any effective
strategies that you've seen well today's
world you have to think about online and
offline you have to be present in both
you need to have your elevator pitch you
need to have your LinkedIn uh resume
you've got to have your bio which is a
shorter resume you you know you need an
array of ways to
communicate who you are and what you're
looking for but I think when you're
talking about a career pivot there's a a
Nuance that's important you need to
connect the dots for people you can't
expect them to do it for you so if you
are looking to make a pivot and your
resume is a chronological list of what
you've done which is pretty much the
that often won't be enough because it's
it's you who's thought through why this
makes sense it's you who's thought
through what it is that's relevant from
your past to your future and you need to
make that clear and so when you are
marketing yourself whether it is in the
online channels or the offline channels
or probably most importantly through
your network so if you're igniting your
network you don't you need to help them
understand here's what I'm trying to do
here's why I'm trying to do it here's
why I think I'm credible and compelling
to do it um because those people the
people who know you well and have
confidence in you as a professional are
the most valuable people to convince
somebody else that you're worth a risk
right so getting those people to
understand and spending the time with
them I often get a lot of phone calls
from people who used to work for me when
they're making pivots um my favorite one
was someone who worked for me who told
me he was really interested in space um
and uh he had been an entertainment
executive and I thought okay let's
that's a hard one you know how are we
going to take the entertainment and
space okay we can do that and but you
know it's important because after
spending time with him I actually was
able to help him connect the dots
connect the dots and how do you make the
argument that this this skill set is
relevant to where you want to go so it's
marketing but it's smart marketing and
it's marketing where you have to do a
little more of the heavy lifting than
you would typically do if your whole
career was in marketing right and you
went up the curve the way you know many
people have done and will continue to do
and then you want to go into another
marketing job it's pretty easy right
this is a different
[Music]
situation I think we've gone through
about four strategies of things to do
but I was intrigued by something you
said which was to to know how to avoid
common mistakes what do you see as
common mistakes that people make in
career transitions so I mean the first
is we talked about it be realistic I
mean a this is not easy B it can take
time you may fail you may go down a path
that doesn't work so you have to
regroup but you've go to you've got to
know that you're going to make it it's
going to be okay but you've got to be
realistic about it and you know very
closely connected is be patient right
because it can take time that's a hard
one sometimes you know lightning could
strike and it does but more likely
you're going to have to navigate this
and figure it out and give yourself
enough time and enough space to um to do
it and that's why you know Project work
is actually an interesting way to keep
yourself busy as you go through this
because oftentimes that can turn into
something that you don't expect right
right well and also it it seems like um
there's phrase that you've used several
times that i' I've always liked which is
embrace the Serendipity is that
opportunities may come up you may not be
ready for them or even want them or you
may not think you want them but you
really should them and you know it's
there there's sort of three things that
are connected you know a you've got to
be realistic you've got to be patient
but you've also got to roll up your
sleeves you may have to take a step back
you may have to do things that feel
uncomfortable right but again you're
trying to forge away into something new
right and so like anything new you know
it's going to feel a little
uncomfortable you're gonna have to do
some things also we always talk about
the importance of teamwork which is of
course important when you're pivoting
you have to think of yourself as a new a
new worker a new employee and you want
to figure out how you can make an
individual impact you want to show that
you can make a contribution and you want
to make it in a way that lets people
understand this is going to work to be
the team player but also be very clear
on what you're bringing to personal
value and and then the Serendipity is
just this is something you've always
said that I like you know it it's
actually as I said the the career that
is
pivoting is going to be unique to
everybody and so one of the reasons that
you want to be fluid and opportunistic
is you know I look at my own career I
could never have written down law to
invest in banking to government to you
know media to Capital you know you would
never have seen that it's a combination
of following what you're interested in
but being Nimble and when the
opportunity comes up so media is a
really good example and this is kind of
another thing for career pivots that I
think people should just keep in mind I
got them opportunity to go into
media precisely because I knew nothing
about it and it was a situation where
there had been an attempt to create a a
new market and the people who knew a lot
about that market were very rigid in
their thinking and they said I know how
to do this and of course it's New Market
so sometimes knowledge can be an
obstacle not um not a plus so they so
they glad they were glad you were
clueless they were glad I didn't know
anything and so again you know you
that's being nimble like I didn't expect
that I could walk into an opportunity in
media because I knew nothing about media
I had no media in my background I got
lucky right found something that was so
I think it it's just keeping your eyes
open being uh receptive to things that
you hadn't thought of but that might
work and trying them and there the other
thing you said which I don't want to you
know skip over is the get your hands
dirty like you may if you're making a
career transition or pivot you may have
to do something that you you may think
was below you or that you your skills
were Beyond exactly but you you do it
you do it because you know where you're
going and you know the thing that's
interesting about this whole area is
we're talking a lot about what an
individual needs to do um to be
successful in a career pivot employers
now have to think more broadly right
about people's career and how to
evaluate that because it's not going to
look like it's always looked and so the
ability to understand that people are
pursuing different um different things
at different times and to be able to
assess and evaluate the quality of that
individual even though it's a lot harder
yeah than it used to be when you said
okay they Advanced up in 2.6 months you
know and so I think it's a new skill for
employers too to be aware that this is
happening at the rate that it's
happening and to adjust their own
expectations and skills honestly um in
order to recognize the great talent
that's out there that is pursuing a
different path it really does feel like
a new normal I think I think we're going
to see more and more people who both
Again by choice or by um by happen St
are finding themselves looking to make a
career pivot and I think they should
feel excited about that opportunity and
uh excited about where it might take
them and it's such an important topic
for individuals as well as for as you
said you know companies yes that need to
access this Talent Jody thank you this
has been a very helpful conversation and
I appreciate you being here also want to
thank the Stanford Alumni Association
The Graduate School of Business and
business talent group for hosting the
session today and want to remind all
Stanford alumni that there are numerous
career services and tools available on
multiple sites but at Stanford alumni
Services as well as the GSB alumni
career services there's a number of
tools that you can access for all of
your lifelong career transition needs
thank you very
much